[Music]
i'm a big fan of you guys been watching
you guys for years and uh i like it when
you make fun of me though oh wait
i deserve it it's boring when people are
just being nice to you so why don't you
guys go ahead and roast me that's what
i'm here for today oh we're here to
roast you about alex jones
are you kidding me i
yeah any any roasting i've ever done has
always been very lighthearted i find it
i find it like it i find it impossible
to hate alex you're my internet that i
literally call it the real truth is
let's not lie you guys both got harrison
smith pregnant yes it was okay so yeah
we hung out when we went to texas he's a
snazzy guy you saw how he dresses what
did you say how did you eat dresses
harrison smith dresses like uh if if
white people were in the nation of islam
you know what i mean very well put
together
you've seen him in a cheerleader outfit
oh no god please don't the sword with
the sword he collects his sword
yeah
no he's he's our favorite guy over there
we love harrison yeah he rules we uh
we're very good pals with him
and you know i i gotta tell you alex
honestly i i do really appreciate that
you just put your foot to the pedal when
people come after you like i've oh let
me see is that him
oh that's there yeah no here it is yeah
no that's the guy i know i know who it
is
i know who it is we showed it yesterday
this guy oh my god this is great this is
great yeah this is
i like that you print what are your
what's your uh
what's your toner budget yeah what's
your toner budget i've wondered that for
years i mean you know you print
everything out you print it out in full
color
every day there's stacks of paper i've
just always wondered let me tell you why
we do that we found they change articles
and it's it and they move them around so
it's good to have a record of it well
did you see yesterday what good morning
america did when they when they said um
they said catanji brown jackson is the
first black supreme court justice ever
and they had it up there and they first
one in history in history and i was like
i see that they don't even care about
it's like the secret service goes
you trump can't even get up in the front
of the limo he didn't do it they're like
oh shut up he did it
like they say there's calls from mark
meadows to me and roger stone and
general flynn never happened never
talked to mark meadows rogers never
talked to him they don't care they just
go ahead with it they don't give a rat's
ass anymore i mean they were always
liars but now they have gone into
overdrive also i think we could admit
you know the size of the limo aside
right i mean you know we like trump
whatever but
physically right he's not he's not
necessarily he's not
i don't i don't see trump wrestling
around with secret service agents you
know what i mean i don't i just don't
picture see i mean you guys know what's
happening it's the initial thing like i
never play this on my own show i
mentioned it but i'm not kidding you
i'm going to tell you the inside
baseball of this not that i'm that
interesting but to know how these frauds
work
before they make a hollywood movie uh
biopic or something about somebody
they don't want to get sued so hollywood
won't do it until it's been in several
publications so john ronson that makes
fraudulent movies like men who stare at
goats to discredit the pentagon and
other shows he goes out and creates an
npr piece that's totally fake about me
the new york times article is totally
fake i read it 95 of it has no
connection reality
it means zero
and then they get it on cnn a few weeks
ago and i'm watching it i didn't watch
it when it aired but i watched it later
and they say that i become
demon-possessed and have a black tongue
that shoots out now obviously that's
meant to sound so outrageous it must be
true but that's because leonardo
dicaprio reportedly has optioned
uh ronson's new new thing and so they
need it to be on tv so they don't get
sued first to say it's real so they're
planning to make a movie
where i become like the exorcist and
have a black tongue i've never heard of
a black tongue my wife is i call her
christian hindu she loves yoga and
eastern stuff and like goes to those
seminars she goes oh that's kali
kali has a black tongue when she cuts
the tyrant's heads off that's a
compliment i've never heard of a black
tongue till this hair
they literally say
i have a black tongue that shoots i mean
i'm telling you dude they have hit
next
level
i don't know this kind of sounds like a
pretty awesome movie if
you know what i mean if you're talking
about it and alex is actually lisa alex
jones with a black tongue shooting beams
out and [ __ ] i mean
i'm not lying take my money thing is
these people are insane but you're right
i hope they come out with a movie but
you're right leonardo i'm not going to
sit you know it's his company option
they option a lot of stuff no they have
they have optioned a movie about me
where they literally
went and had people reverse engineer and
make up an insane script so they could
put it out so they could do the based on
real life events thing at the front of
it right yeah what they do all the time
um how much do you want to bet because
we've watched this happen a thousand
times right they shoot themselves kind
of gross i didn't brush my teeth
it's got plaque on it you got a scrape
yeah you got it you got a scrape
i mean i mean like that's kind of ah
mine too i
mine too i had a few drinks last night
so yeah that's why
i check this let's fact check this
that's a pink and white tongue but
listen how many times has the left tried
to make it a hit piece and it's
backfired and just made the subject look
cooler i just feel like that's going to
happen with this i agree but if new
listeners are new viewers
i swear to god
they say i turn into a demon and have a
black tongue and i swear to god that's
not true
but you know did you eat i mean it's
like it's the most insane you're
watching this and you're like you ever
been around insane people like i got a
cousin schizophrenic or whatever and
you're around him for a few hours you
kind of start feeling crazy it's like
you're watching this you're like do i
have a black tongue i wouldn't did i
yeah i mean it's like where what i'm
asking you guys both
i think they've gone insane well can i
can i ask maybe was this maybe this
story came from a time were you eating
some sort of uh one of those like sour
candy licorice a licorice were you in a
licorice were you drinking a lot of
sambuca maybe you know what i mean maybe
you were enjoying a nice uh tiramisu
with some sleep never heard this in my
life
no here now
this is great because this leads into
something i wanted to ask you
it's funny because like they they try to
now we're finding out literally demonize
you right
and now they're literally demonizing you
and then but then every time i watch
something right i go
oh they took
they took that from alex like look like
here's a great example hey that's a new
meme look at this that is a new one here
here's this guys you can make you can
make the gif right there he did the
tongue thing there it is there it is
so
what do you think about this i was
watching this and every time i watch
something i always catch this they they
always want to demonize you but man they
have parodies of what you do in every
movie like this is a great example this
is from the new spider-man they can't
get you out of their head
you have look at that
they took your font they took your set
wielding powers
to possess trying to pass himself off
what do you think of that well i always
wonder what do you think when you see
stuff like that stevens on this on the
movie goes and i have a supplement you
really need exactly exactly but also
alpha power available
right now there it is free plug for
alpha power on the show also how is jay
jonah jameson wrong in this movie no
he's spiderman and all these mutants
they're they're menaces they have super
powers they're blowing up skyscrapers
every two to three years it's a problem
right he's the good guy it's a sensible
take yeah what do you think when they do
that out of curiosity because i see it
all the time alex what do you think what
do you think when they do they're not
coming for all of gotham they're coming
for batman let's just get batman out of
here
you know
you know i'll tell you
you know that
um
bon ivers who they have in the headline
but it's like alex jones bon iver's song
and had like 20 million views and they
took it down it's like 9 million views
where i said we love asamolas we love
muslims too you know that song yes yes
where they remixed you into about it and
i'm going to know that guy's actually
really a fan
but they say they're anti anti-alex
jones and they're able to do it so i
actually talked to some of the folks in
hollywood over the years and if they go
with a script the big guys saying we're
going to attack alex jones and we're
going to do this to them these people
are like 80 90 years old like some of
the redstone before he died
and they go yeah get that piece of [ __ ]
and then all that happens is then it's
actually fans putting it out there so i
think most that's fan based yeah it is
and you know i was actually watching
this new and dumped because i was
curious this new mike myers show on
netflix at penn tavres and they again
they do another infowars parody well
that one's even clearer i mean it's
literally the set he's yeah stuff i'm
saying out of context yeah exactly and i
couldn't find a clip on that because it
was on youtube but because it's mike
myers new show and nobody nobody cares
about it it's mike it's a new show
nobody cares because it's not austin
powers anymore but i honestly believe
that
it's exactly what mercy like they try to
make you look bad and all it does is
make you cooler like i'm like
it really does like
they they've taken you guys off of
youtube they've taken you guys off of
everything but everyone talks about you
guys even more i want to be clear i
actually agree with what you just said
i'm actually not that cool i mean i got
a lot of good ideas a lot of great
research we do a good radio show and tv
show
but this happens throughout history when
they said copernicus and galileo were
wrong or you know when the colonies got
attacked by great britain people
secretly in britain were sending money
to support it
we're the black sheep we're the rebels
so it's not that we're that good you
guys are popular too it's that they're
that bad and so we can be really
horrible we're not horrible you know
we're just okay but they're so horrible
it makes us look great that's it all
right so you're saying is that they've
lowered the bar so much
and i really think they have i think
that's a good point they've lowered the
bar so much that anybody that even
speaks a little bit of truth now people
like hey why that why is that guy saying
everything different from everything
else you know did you hear ben shapiro
that young genius said communism isn't
good man he's an incredible young man
yeah wow
probably got a 5 000 iq yeah i know cool
yeah i love ben shapiro he only goes on
cnn and msnbc but yeah he's really
fighting for you guys
i mean and that's the thing and the
other thing that's happened is is that
there's these every there there's these
plants
where that that they go no you see we
let right wing people on i'm like the
people that you let on are are you know
milk toast yeah they're like oh
no i'm a republican but i'm all about
red flag laws exactly hey common sense
gun reform i've been saying it for years
and you're like you're not a republican
you realize it's free crime all these
mass shooters they had tons of warnings
oh yeah these mass shooters said they
were going to shoot everybody whether it
was florida a few years ago or you yeah
every every few years
and then now it's the end of due process
and now the leftist here's an example i
know a very well-known
young lady
uh i was at her wedding last weekend to
jessie james bonnie rotten
uh is her stage name that's how she's
known but great lady great great mother
you know we were not blaming her for
which you know what she's been involved
in hell i wish i was involved in it but
the point is
friends
we all hang out
she was on a flight back to la to visit
family
uh yesterday and just because who she
was a leftist said she's racist she's
gonna threaten to shoot people and they
pulled her out the plane and put her
back on it because the person on the
plane
literally just lied and said things
about her that's who the left are what
you were saying earlier is key
they are not just going to try to ban us
with things like red flag laws when
they're taking your rights and when
they're saying because of what political
group you're in you're losing your
freedoms that's already the social
script
the social credit score and so we
already have the social credit score
right now that they're putting into
place
oh yeah no i mean look the social credit
score one we were just talking about it
right before you came on and this is
exactly right it's what you said so you
know now they want to go through your uh
new york just said that they're passing
they're gonna pass a new bill with the
unelected governor uh hulkel
uh i was watching i was sitting here i
didn't know that
like you they're like hey tell them i'm
here for 10 minutes and they go well you
have to interrupt him so yeah you're
going to have money i was watching yeah
so what do you think about that bill
what do you think about that bill about
them being able to go through your
entire social media to decide if you get
to have a second amendment
and then they have a special committee
that does it it's like the fact checkers
it's extra judicial groups
it's like fauci's wife
runs the bioethics federal board that
decides how many old people to euthanize
with death panels it is i mean i have
paul krugman on fox news and i have
ezekiel emanuel on fox news both of them
saying a combination of death panels and
taxes will kill the old people so this
is all about killing the boomers and the
boomers are there going yeah get rid of
our rights kill the babies and kill us
it it you know it really is true they
they really are they they there's a lot
of cheering on their own destruction
like you know one of my biggest
criticisms and i've seen you say the
same thing to my biggest christmas about
trump is how he pushed that vaccine how
he said how great it was and i came even
today he's like i made the vaccine it's
the best vaccine in the history of the
world it was the beginning of the end
for him that was to me was when i think
you know the people that really got him
elected i think the people that really
got trump elected aren't so much like
you said the boomers that are out there
waving maggot flags it was the people
that were sick and tired right sick and
tired of the swamp sick and tired of
telling them and those were the people
that i think he lost when he was like
we're going to send the national guard
and they're going to inject you and i'm
like what wait what's happening yeah he
was absolutely right when he was
debating biden he invoked images of
we'll get flatbed trucks we'll get the
military out there and we'll distribute
this vaccine and i was like
what
what happened in four years
what are you talking about like i would
expect biden to be saying that right now
it was
that that was like a punch in my gut man
yeah
well that's what really hurt trump and
that's why the samus and real polls is
ahead of trump not that the samus didn't
go along with it but he didn't launch it
like trump did i understand they locked
down the economy
i understand they were holding trump
hostage saying oh it'll be five years
ten years
too bad things will be locked down until
then and like a five-year-old he took
the bait and went we'll do it all just
to prove it they go gee we have a plan
called warp speed to do that with this
experimental shot but now that he's had
time to see it's a fraud now that he's
had time to see that it doesn't give you
protection like they said
now he still goes along with it which is
the biggest
uh
black mark
on his record it's really really really
really hurting
and you're right people voted for trump
because they saw the media attacking him
and they thought well let's be
rebellious but as soon as he joined the
establishment people really turned
against him now that's on one side
on the other side the roe v wade
decision which should go back to the
states the pro-gun decision the
anti-carbon tax decision shutdown the
power plants uh the pro-free speech
decision with prayer this is not
state-run prayer it's not the school
doing the prayer it's people at their
commencement speech or whatever having a
right to say whatever they want you know
you could uh sing
railroad row your boat gently down the
stream or say a prayer or hail satan
it's your right to do what you want your
commencement of your event and so that
was a really good thing by the supreme
court uh but uh you know trump just
doesn't get it people want a maverick
they want a black sheep they want a
rebel they don't want somebody telling
you how they're gonna have the military
give you an experimental shot so
he's at least shut up about the shot but
the damage is done and i don't know if
trump is salvageable right now yeah
that's that's our worry we talked about
that you guys aren't getting desantis
yet he's ours for two years we're in
florida you're not touching him for
another two years he belongs to us
yeah that's the thing is we're in
florida right and you're right desantis
at the very beginning did lock down but
if you look at all the other governors
it was the shortest lockdown of any out
of any state right
no i mean look it's okay to be wrong up
front and then change direction and now
he's badass now he's like admit it well
he admitted
he admitted it i think that was the big
part the part the difference between
right now the reason i like you like you
mentioned that desantis is beating trump
is because desantis went out there on
camera goes yeah i went along with it
i'm not to fall for it again i'm done
and it's not going to happen look
nobody's perfect right exactly nobody as
long as you admit you're wrong i'm wrong
all the time but but
there's no way desantis is a fraud with
what he's doing he is hurting the
establishment bad i love it yeah yeah
i'm sorry florida doesn't get him
yeah
back and forth we don't have anything
that's all we got i just need two more
years with this guy all right he's
single he's single-handedly keeping us
alive through this presidency you know
what i mean like we don't have it pretty
much he's our only oxygen with biden
pretty much ruining everything coast to
coast
florida's at least on life support yeah
i mean
would be in the hell of a president
though he would help florida at the same
time you can have him when we're done
with them we have we have term limits
here don't worry yeah don't get crazy go
get greedy yeah all right don't get
greedy let us you know let's get that
constitutional carry the recreational
marijuana through and you're gonna have
it hey by the way you know what the
other reason i think texans like uh
desantis we bring it up all the time is
because uh your uh your governor copies
whatever desantis does copies his
homework exactly i mean i mean
our governor has been a shame the last
three years yeah until desantis came
along and now like a parrot he does
whatever sanus does at least in word not
deed yeah he's the kid he's the kid next
to you leaning over towards your desk
like what is he saying what is he saying
what do you have for number three i mean
i'm a good speaker you guys are good
speakers
the stannis isn't reading off a
teleprompter when he's talking you can
see it he gives like 10 20 minute
speeches that are like
99s and i give like a 95 speech i mean
these are badass well thought out
nuanced speeches nobody's telling him
what to say uh i'm impressed i mean i'll
just be honest with you and i don't have
a savior complex i don't think he's
perfect but as things get worse and
worse
we're going to see more ron desantis
rise up just by sheer necessity you know
the mother of invention
necessity is another intervention